hi guys today I'm gonna play it again
that you might have seen around before I
originally saw this a few weeks back at
egx rezzed which is a load of indie
games and as soon as I saw some guy
playing this I just burst out laughing
it is probably one of the most weirdest
games I've ever laid my eyes on I've
finally decided just to buy it and try
it myself I'm sure you guys will enjoy
it if you haven't already seen it it's
cool plug and play and as you can see I
just kind of have to plug things oh I
got click so when I saw this that egx I
didn't actually play and I didn't hear
this ridiculous music these are very
long fingers Oh woohoo oh oh okay what
just happened okay mm-hmm off he goes
please come back oh hello are you okay
little plug plug man what are you doing
you know toward your belly put your plug
your arm your leg feet am i beating up
the plug man i feel bad i don't want to
do this can I dragged him hola making
him run again that's fun all right oh
hey okay what okay
whew that moves it's like a sneak attack
no they're just press the button it's
not Fred it should be fine okay look at
this hello hello hello hello oh no
you're going the wrong way he's pritzker
this way hello oh ok why what is are
they attached to each other what well
listen what's the meaning of this ok
hello look hello oh that was a bit
vicious push him nap you push it up oh
ok oh look at more are you pushing now
ah Bishop now you're all alone so
anything else like to do with this
button pop them
I have to oh now it's right black white
black white okay OOP OOP yeah there's
never flirt to plug into no oh my gosh
oh the secrets OOP cool now what oh
you're an Indiana now see now you're a
second look at your bum wait what are
you doing Oh what do I do that uh-huh I
always see you right so that's where the
little work that's whether the two bits
they went down and through his body and
then put it back out right cuz that
makes total sense yes no
this gave me so expected comic buttons
okay oh look hello bye bye see you oh I
thought he would be offended no go back
to him and say hi I feel bad now hey
dinner ah oh it's okay oh wow do you
know me know me tea I know you oh it's a
boy and a girl do you see the references
Oh No uh I don't know I don't you you I
know you do i do you do you do do you
yes yes no no no yes I thought it was
gonna be stuck in an infinite yeah an
infinite loop then and yes it is okay I
really bad at this communication things
i love you i love you i don't think oh I
love you I think you don't love me [ __ ]
me I'm not sure oh but I do love you I
don't is the saddest love story ever it
really is
it's okay I'm over it now right you
stick it out oh come on Gemma Gemma come
on haha yeah you night Oh Sees guys
again they confuse me I don't know what
they're doing oh oh [ __ ] it's so cute
oh ok uh-huh uh-huh they seem to be
connected i don't know if that's
supposed to be it has like normal or not
and let me know guys at me and i want to
join in command yeah yes hmm it's not
right get out of that it's know it's
weird oh I see where this is going I'm
very unsure about this oh dear these
plugs are just a metaphor oh I've messed
it up now look I messed it up oh ok
can come to me come to me no you come to
me yes ah now what oh oh I don't know I
feel about this game um I don't even
know what how to comment comment on what
I'm looking at like what the noise is
well what am i watching get out get out
right integrate these plugs oh look as
the holy thing is again maybe I should
intercept nope okay
cut my finger what is this it's a new
way of handshaking what am i doing oh
it's a confused this is so much fun
though like weirdly I don't understand
why I enjoy it I'm disturbed yet
intrigued and having fun at the same
time put the fingers look in the second
oh my gosh oh that's so creepy is that
the end do you just oh it is the end but
no I guess so weird okay well that was
without a doubt the most weirdest game
that I've ever played I normally ramble
on about the narrative and things like
that and stuff that I loved about the
game but I seriously I'm just speechless
I don't understand how I can be so
disturbed and terrified but at the same
time really intrigued and having fun at
the same time and I feel like like I
should feel bad about feeling that way
I'll bet the link in the description if
you want to check it out for yourself
and please start a discussion down below
what the hell just happened in that game
because I don't really know for once I
am speechless anyway I hope you enjoyed
the video and give it a thumbs up if you
did and have a lovely day or evening bye
okay feels pretty cool down the rabbit
hole it's like Alice in Wonderland